how much diligence do you do on the
companies coming into the accelerator
because they are very nascent
what does diligence look like coming
into your accelerator the alchemist
accelerator
it's three basic phases there's a
written application that gets assessed
um on the classic things that you would
look for for any company then we
do a second phase which is the people so
we do try to reference the people
if we have connections between the
founders and alchemists in the community
and get
thoughts on how those people are and
then there's an in-person
interview and an assessment in person
that might lead to also further
diligence and in the in-person
interview usually there's three people
that are interviewing each of the
startups one's usually representing the
vcs one's usually a former alum of
alchemist and once usually a successful
founder
accepting people in these early stages
means you're going to make a lot of
mistakes
that's part of the game right is to if
you're going to get in early you're
going to accept people who you will
eventually regret having accepted or
you know who might disappoint you um
how do you deal with having your name on
a company
where you're no longer rooting for the
founder where the founder has
disappointed you
or behaved badly uh
how do you deal with that as an
accelerator with them as a graduate with
your logo in their deck
the only way a founder disappoints us is
if they act unethically if they're if
they're acting
into something which happens but it's
very rare so it has happened to us but
it's probably happened once
out of the 300 companies that we've
funded just to be clear yeah so i just
want to
make a distinction between that and not
succeeding so
we actually think that it's not
necessarily a failure if you didn't
financially succeed as long as you
as long as you did it with all of your
heart and the reality for us is that if
we had 100 percent success
we're not taking enough risk of course
we we
want to be constantly quote unquote
failing we want to be
you know exploring new markets like we
you know we funded a uh
anti-matter company called posit well
positrons great and you guys should
check them out but that's going to be a
path to
figuring out how to build anti-matter to
get to mars um and
you know the timing on that maybe it may
have been different than righty which is
a quantum computing company
but i love them both because they're
both really
true entrepreneurs they're not starting
a company because they want to be a
founder they want to actually change the
world so when you do have the bad
behavior which happens once in a while
what do you do how do you manage that as
an investor
that's very unfortunate and this is
where um you have to separate your roles
from the coach
of the of the company to being the
fiduciary for this for the community
so you know i i am your first and
foremost the the cheerleader of the
founder
but i am also a fiduciary for the
investors and for
all of our customers and all the other
mentors that are stakeholders that we
um that that that trust us when we're
introducing the company so
it is not um uh if if somebody's doing
something unethic
basically what will happen here is that
you have to deliberately do something
that is unethical or
misrepresenting yourself or doing
something that was clearly um
wrong and i know there can be gray lines
an entrepreneurship around this but i'm
talking about something that's just like
clear-cut that's clear yeah and if you
did that then what normally happens is
that
we're assessing um
the the the reality is that what i'm
looking at is i'm looking at the
business
i'm looking at the ethical issues and
i'm looking at the legal issues and then
i'm trying to make an assessment on all
those then make a plan against that
i'll usually talk to the founder
directly and ideally have a path where
there's
they're going to be invited to remedy
the situation in a mutually consensual
way but that usually will require that
um founder to take some hard medicine
and to accept
that path and if they don't accept it
then it has to we have to do what's
right
and we have to protect all the
stakeholders that are involved yeah
it's the unfortunate part about what we
do and you know when you're in this
early stage i've had it happen where i
just told people like you know
you don't need to have me on your cap
table why don't oh yeah you just rip up
the term sheet
send us back the money and we'll all
move on no
i've done that as well yeah it's just
like life is short like no one
investment
uh is likely to make a difference when
you get past two or three hundred i mean
obviously an outlier of outliers will if
you have to invest in google or facebook
but
in in most cases like that company
that's having the problems is actually
not going to be
that company anyway so just rip up the
term shape send the money back
send half of it back whatever you know
well i mean we've had but
even if we don't you know even if we've
already invested we'll tell people you
know you don't need to mention us on
your cap table and you can just
move forward even if it's been like
after the company's graduated and
but that doesn't happen that you know it
doesn't it's not it's not that often